welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's kino presentation
fully automated ihc multiplexing
techniques and assay development
presented by dr mark halliwell discovery
reagent and training lead
companion diagnostics and discovery
roche tissue diagnostics
my name is xavier gutierrez and i will
be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by roche diagnostics
for more information about our sponsor
please visit www.diagnostics.roche.com
now before we begin i would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during the presentation
simply click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and type your questions into the drop
down box our speaker will respond to
your questions via email following the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the ask
a question box to let us know that
you're experiencing a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
now without further ado please join me
in welcoming dr heliwol
i will now turn the presentation over to
him
so we're going to begin with some
background and utility form
multiplexing within the research market
for tissue diagnostics
this has been one of the fastest growing
and most
popular areas of interest within
research
and that's down to the fact that you can
basically perform multiple
detections of markers on the same
section of tissue
and this is particularly useful for
research because
in most cases we're dealing with
pressure samples
we're looking at panel developments or
multiple markers relating to
a particular disease area or the
companion diagnostic development which
may be
researched we can also look at
co-localization and
interaction um in terms of how those
proteins are being expressed and how
they're interacting within
with each cell in terms of the
the tissue itself in
also in relation to this we can look at
cell population studies
particularly looking at expression
patterns and also looking at the
organization of the tumor
all of this leading towards an increased
diagnostic and predictive
accuracy at the moment a lot of the
multiplexing work we're seeing is
being performed within the research
sector but we hope within the few years
next few years we will see this moving
forward towards the
towards the clinical space and in turn
increasing medical value
for clinical diagnostics
so in terms of multiplexing uh two
different key methods
for ihc multiplexing and that's using
fluorescence or chromogenic detection
historically fluorescence has been the
method of choice because it's
easy to see where there is
co-localization of markers basically
where two
different fluorescent markers overlap it
creates a second color
in the past for chromogens with
traditional chromogens such as dab and
red
when these do co-localize it's very
difficult to see where these
co-localization events are occurring
however with the introduction of our new
chromogens which have translucent
properties
we can see color changes so these
chromogens act just like
fluorophores and when they do overlap it
creates a new colour
which is a great benefit for people that
don't have fluorescent equipment to be
able to detect these particular markers
one of the big advantages for
multiplexing as well
is automation um we have automated
platforms which
take away the complexity of the
multiplexing assay
within this slide you can see in the top
right hand corner is a manual workflow
diagram which shows all the touch points
which would have to take place
to create a a manual iac assay
with multiplexing however with
automation we take away a lot of those
touch points and provide full
standardization
reduce bench time and also with the
introduction of ready-to-use products
we can ensure that we get a high level
of reproducibility across
any assays which are developed
so with chromogenic multiplexing which
is the area we're going to focus on
primarily
it's really expanded over the past uh
two to three years
with the introduction of these new
chromogens and the
expansion of the automation that we can
offer within roche tissue diagnostics so
at the moment we're seeing five
six different markers on the same slide
and here we've just got a few examples
of what we can offer in terms of
fully automated and ready to use
multiplexing detection
and as i mentioned earlier this is all
down to how the new chromogens work
conventional chromogens such as fast red
and fast blue
have a very broad absorbance spectra
and this means they're very difficult to
deconvolute and if they overlap
it's very difficult to see different
colors emerging
if we lay over additional chromogens and
counter stains such as hematoxylin dab
and silver
you can see there's such a broad array
of spectra there that it's going to be
very difficult to see
co-localization events
the new discovery chromogens that we've
created are very much based around
a hp inkjet printer where you would have
three different colour cartridges which
are able to create
any particular colour you like by
overlapping
you can see here that each of the
discovery chromogens discovery yellow
purple and teal all have very narrow
absorbent spectra so when they do
overlap
it's very different it's very easy to
see where these co-localization events
take place
and also very easy to deconvolute using
image analysis tools
so with our translucent chromogens as i
mentioned we do
show the same properties of fluorescence
so basically where
co-localization takes place we can see
a new color emerging so here we've got
two examples
of the co-localization staining where we
have discovery purple and discovery
yellow
and when they co-localize as a dual
stain it creates this new color which is
a
a dark red or an orange color so you can
see where those co-localization
events are going to going to happen
another example here is where we've got
teal for cd163
and yellow for cd68 and when they
co-localize it creates the green color
which you can see in this image
the same two markers cd 163 cd68 in
purple and
teal and when these co-localize we get
this
a dark blue or indigo color showing
where the co-localization of
events take place and obviously the huge
benefit here
is that you don't need any specialist
filters you don't need a fluorescent
scope
all of this can be visualized under a
bright field microscope
so let's talk a little bit about method
and
assay development for multiplexing
multiplexing is a
complex area there's no rulebook in
terms of how
these assays are created but with our
experience with the research
tissue research market that we've been
working in we've put together this
presentation which will
give you some outlines as to how to
create your multiplex assays
so let's look at some of the methods of
detection so this first method here
we're going to talk about is an
anti-species approach
where we deposit our fluorophores or our
chromogens with an enzyme so the big
advantage here
is um there isn't really any species
limitations
the the way in which the enzyme
enzymatic
deposition occurs allows us to have an
increased signal intensity
greater stability and much easier to
transfer between
a fluorescence and a bright field
procedure
downsides here can that can be that the
assays do take a little bit longer
and if you are using certain flaws they
can be
bleached or they can be susceptible to
any denaturing or quench steps and this
can happen
by h202 which is quite commonly used
within these types of assays
these are a couple of the detection
methods that we have available
for the discovery so this is an
anti-species or anti-hatan approach with
enzyme
deposited chromogens on the left hand
side we have the multimode detection
which basically is a an anti-species
secondary antibody and conjugated to
that
is your enzyme which is going to drive
the chromogenic reaction
and in this case it can be either hrp or
ap
on the right hand side we have a hapten
detection method
and here what we use is a proprietary
product created at roche tissue
diagnostics
whereby we conjugate a hapten or a
synthetic
label to a secondary antibody so in this
case we use hq or np
and then we come in with an antibody
directed against these synthetic
labels so we come in with an anti-hq hrp
or an anti-np-ap with this
we really see a huge increase in
specificity
sensitive sensitivity and signal
intensity
and we can use this method with
chromogens or fluorophores
and these are excellent for detecting
low expressing targets
so once we've decided on the type of
detection method that we're going to
implement
we recommend not diving straight into a
multiplex assay what we advise is
optimizing each antibody individually
so once you've decided on the panel that
you're creating
optimize each of those individually work
out which
marker is going to work best with each
detection type with
each chromogen type and then create your
staining reference library so you've
always got something to go back to
in order to determine uh if that stain
is working effectively if you were to
dive straight into a
four or five plex assay it's very
difficult to work out what may or may
not have gone wrong with the assay if
there are problems
at the end of the the staining ground by
having that reference library
you can go back and ensure that
everything is working effectively in
each of the different detection methods
one of the biggest issues we find with
multiplexing assays is actually creating
an assay where
the different markers are able to be
configured with their different antigen
retrieval methods
so in some cases different markers react
differently to different types of
antigen retrieval
and it's important that we try and find
some common ground so trying to find a
retrieval method which is going to suit
all the different antigens within that
particular tissue
section with the software that we have
available for the discovery what we can
offer is progressive retrieval
and what we mean by that is basically
being able to add
additional retrieval as we go through
the the procedure
so you may start off with your in your
first sequence by staining something
which has a very light antigen retrieval
and then towards the end of the the
sequence we've
added or progressively added more
retrieval to hits those additional
antigens throughout the sequences
the two key main the two main types of
retrieval that we
use or our customers use would be either
a heat retrieval or enzymatic retrieval
and as i mentioned with with heat try
and find a method that's efficient for
all the antigens
we can add additional heat applications
through each sequences
and then we can also use different types
of retrieval buffers so in terms of
a high or a low ph retrieval buffer for
each of the different markers
enzymatic retrieval can be a little bit
problematic because it can have a
negative effect
on other targets within the tissue so in
this case if you do have to use an
enzyme we always recommend using that in
the final sequence so you're not going
to affect any of the other markers
within that particular multiplex assay
as i mentioned as well we we offer
either sequential
or cocktailed uh multiplexing options
so with the sequential method uh what we
do is we actually apply each antibody in
detection
individually and then we move on to the
next sequence and in between each of
these sequences we perform a denaturing
or releasing step
which avoids any cross reactivity by
breaking down the
initial antibodies which may have been
applied
this allows us to use uh the same
species same enzyme detection so you may
wish
as you can see in this diagram we can
use all mouse primary antibodies and we
can also use all
hrp enzymes to drive the chromogenic
reactions
just by applying those denaturing steps
between each sequence
with the cocktailed antibodies you can
see here that we can actually
apply two different species
at the same time and as you can see as
well by applying two different
enzymes uh we can perform up to
four different markers over two
sequences by performing this cocktail
method this can be a little bit
problematic
because you have to ensure that all your
detections are configured correctly
but it can help by reducing some of the
run time
antibody detection sequence is also a
key
importance as you can see here we've got
two examples of the same
stain but using different types of
detection so it's important to determine
the optimal type of detection that
you're going to be using
so on the left hand side we've got a
multimode detection
and on the right hand side we've got
hapten based detection
and you can see the increased
sensitivity and specificity of the
hapten detection
is giving a more optimal signal from
that particular
state so it's important to ensure you're
using the best possible detection before
you create
the the multiplex assay
if you plan to use a silver detection as
well it's also important to be
conscious that it can be affected by
hydrogen peroxide treatment or hrp
neutralization and this should be placed
last in the sequence because it can
cause fading to that particular silver
chromosome
so dab is a traditional chromogen used
in ihc
and it's a great chromogen but we can
see problems when we're actually using
it within a multiplex assay
so here we're going to talk about
something that we call the umbrella
effect of dav
and dab we we think inhibits staining of
other markers in close proximity
uh by basically creating a molecular
shell
so what you can see here is if we try
and stain our marker
with dab you can see it creates the the
dab
deposits around that particular marker
and next to it we have another
antibody which isn't in such close
proximity
and we can come in and we can stain that
effectively
so the left-hand side of the the dab
marker
you can see a third and the molecular
shell that we say with the the dab
can actually prevent that particular
marker coming in to bind effectively
with the staining images on this picture
as well what you can see
is that just by alternating the position
of the dab stain we can actually
improve the quality of the staining so
on the left hand side
we've used dab as the first marker for
cd20
and it's very difficult here to see the
cd30 and silver
and just by swapping these over and
putting cd30 first
cd 22nd you can see that the the
staining is a much more apparent
and just these changes in sequence can
have a big impact on
chromogenic multiplexing
so here we really need to consider
consider market localization
um ideally and this isn't always going
to happen
um it would be optimal to consider
markers that don't overlap
this is quite difficult in most cases so
if you do need to choose markers that
are
are going to overlap it's important to
choose the correct chromogens that you
may wish to use
so here we can see by using as ki-67 in
yellow and cd20 with purple
it's very easy to see where the
co-localization takes place
however below where we have cd8 in
purple
cd3 and silver it's very difficult we
just get a
almost a black stain and it's very
difficult to see where those two
different markers are
so here we have an example of this
chromogen sequence
and changing these to actually create
the best
staining outcome at the end of the
sequence
so here we have cda cd3 and what we
recommend doing is actually creating
a four different slides with
different combinations of firstly the
primary antibody
and then secondly the detection so we
start off with cd3 cd8
and then in the second set of slides we
swap over the primaries and we use cd8
followed by cd3 you can see here just by
swapping
the order of the detection and the
primary antibody
it really has a big impact on the type
of staining that you would see
with the two images on the left being
more optimal because you can see the
purple
and you can also see the dav staining
so one of the key rules of thumb that we
have seen is
we would suggest always staining the
lower expresso first
to give the best possible staining
i touched on this briefly uh earlier so
denaturation and
neutralization and these are methods to
prevent
cross reactivity within a sequential
multiplex staining
so an example would be if you're using
two mouse primary antibodies
if you didn't perform denaturation
this is what would happen what would
happen is you would come in with your
first primary antibody your secondary
and then your chromogen
without denaturation you would start on
your second sequence
you'd come in with another mouse primary
antibody
you come in with another anti-mouse
secondary antibody
the problem here would be that without
denaturation
that secondary antibody would actually
bind to the previously
bound primary antibody creating cross
reactivity within the stain
as you can see here
neutralization is a way of deactivating
hrp enzymes which would be conjugated to
your secondary antibody
so if we weren't to perform
neutralization
we would come in with the primary
secondary conjugated to hrp
it would perform the chromogenic
reaction
and then in the second sequence we would
do the same again we would come in with
the
primary the secondary
because this is also conjugated to hrp
any remaining hrp from the previously
bound complex
actually creates cross reactivity within
the stain
so we would see both bab and purple
staining non-specifically potentially
different sites within the tissue
so how do we go about performing
denaturation and neutralization
so we've got three different methods
that we advise the use of
firstly heat denaturation which can be
used when it's the same primary antibody
species
and also when it's the same hr the same
enzyme species as well
with the same enzyme type what we found
is by performing a
low ph high sds buffer such as ultra c2
at a high heat this actually deactivates
both the
immunoglobulin complexes and also the
enzyme that
you're actually using within that
particular assay
we can also use acid denaturation so by
using a very low ph
solution such as discovery antibody
denaturing reagent
this can help deactivate and neutralize
any previously bound primary antibodies
within the sequence
if you're looking just to perform hrp
neutralization without any
denaturation then you can also use
discovery inhibitor or hydrogen peroxide
to deactivate the hrp conjugates
previously bound
when we do perform denaturation this is
what happens
we come in with primary the secondary
and the chromogen
we apply a high heat and ultra cc2
so that's the low ph high sds buffer
and what this does is it's going to
break down those previously bound
immunoglobulin
globulins such as the primary and the
secondary antibody
meaning when we come in with our next
sequence we have our primary
our secondary and this secondary is only
going to
bind to the primary because it has
nothing else to bind to
so this means we're going to get two
discrete signals without any cross
reactivity
with neutralization again
we come in with our primary our hrp
conjugated secondary
apply our chromogen and then we apply
h2o2 or discovery inhibitor and this is
going to deactivate
any remaining hrps within
the tissue that when we come in with our
second
primary antibody
conjugated to hrp again we're just going
to be left with two discrete signals
so with the denaturing or illusion
methods that we can offer
as i mentioned before we we tend to
recommend the use of
a high heat and a low ph
buffer to perform this type of
denaturation
but you can do this in different ways so
we have a chemical elution
using the antibody denaturing reagent
which is a
a very acidic solution which is is
pretty useful for
when you're using maybe a low order
multiplex but by applying acid
continually to a high order multiplex
this can start to interfere with
morphology across the tissue
the second image is using reaction
buffer or a tbs buffer
with high heat and you can see this also
is effective but by performing a
combination of
acid and heat you can see that the
actual
staining can start to deteriorate
because the
antigenicity starts to be affected by
the different types of volution methods
one way to check your denaturation
efficiency is to run drop
out controls and this basically means by
removing a component of the assay
we can actually check to see whether the
denaturing is working
so on your test protocol you can see
we've got two targets
and we're staining with a anti-mouse
uh secondary and also an anti-mouse
secondary within the
second sequence so here by
performing a dropout control on the
second protocol
by taking away the two chromogens or
taking away the first chromogen
and then the second primary if we see no
cross reactivity we should see no
staining if we see any staining at all
and then that's telling us that that
cross-reactivity is taking place because
we shouldn't be able to see
any cross-reactivity um if the
denaturation
has been effective
okay so let's move on to actually how to
create a protocol
and throughout all of these methods we
always assume that we've started with a
single stain
and we've created a staining reference
so we'll start off
but with a three-plex assay where we
need to consider pre-treatments
antibody species marker localization and
the detection types that we're going to
be using
so the tissue here that we're going to
use is long and we're going to be
running it with ttf1
so that's five cinnamon cd56 with
purple and yellow and based on the
single staining references that we've
created we've decided that we're going
to run
ttf1 with dab which is nuclear synaptic
which is cytoplasmic with yellow and
cd56
staining the membrane with purple
and here we've given you two examples of
optimal and non-optimal staining so on
the left hand side is
what we think is a good quality stain we
started off with
nuclear staining with dav followed by
the cytoplasmic staining in yellow and
then finally the
the cd56 with purple
on the right-hand side is non-optimal
and what we've done here is actually to
swap around
the sequence just to show you what would
happen if we were to run
dab last in the sequence and what you
can see here is the
dab has almost masked everything else
within that particular stain
so it's really important to be sure
where you're going to be using your dab
in this case dab is excellent for
nuclear staining for some of the lower
expressing markers
within a multiplex
so the next one we'll look at is a
fourplex assay
in this one we have a lymph node and
we're staining it with cd30
cd20 cd4 cd8 and we're going to be using
dab
purple teal and silver again we've
assumed
that we've optimized using our single
stain references
and therefore we've created the
following um initial stain which is cd30
and silver
cd4 in teal cd8 in purple and cd20 and
d8b
and what we've done here is actually
we've created an expression ratio
and as i mentioned before we always
recommend running the lower expressing
marker first so cd30 cd4 and cd8 should
be
equivocal in terms of expression ratio
and then cd20 is going to be the high
expresso
and here we've created an example where
we've actually used dab
as the high expresso which isn't always
advisable as you can see from the
staining image
and what you can see here is the cd20 is
almost masking
every other color within that tissue
section
you can see a little bit of the teal but
it's really difficult to see the
purple or the silver coming through
within that particular stain
so what we're going to do here is
actually move the cd20
further down the sequence whereby
cd30 remains in first position cd 20 in
the second position
you can see immediately just by changing
the order of that sequence
some of the other markers now become
apparent
so ideally within this particular
example we probably wouldn't use dab as
our
chromogene of choice just purely because
of the
number of markers that we're trying to
detect and the way in which dab can mask
other markers but we're just using this
as
a example for you to see where we
actually
can move around the different sequences
and this will actually
create a more improved stain and
visualization method
another example here is uh the use of
red and purple
and what we found is that red actually
gets more pink in terms of its hue
if you use it in later steps within the
sequence
so on the top left image we've used cd8
with purple cd68 red
ki 67 in yellow and then a pan keratin
with teal
you can see that the the red staining is
very dark
with for the cd68 however if we on the
right hand side move cd68 to the last
part of the sequence
the hue has changed completely and it's
actually looking a little bit more like
the purple
so it's very difficult to actually
notice the contrast between the two
different markers
so it's important to consider where
you're actually going to be using these
different chromogens within the sequence
another example here um where we're
using co-localized antigens of cd30 and
cd20
the top left uh is the optimal staining
where we've used cd31s cd20 cd8
and then cd ki 67 in teal
and you can see that by moving the
different
sequences around it actually really
changes the way in which the staining
works so
the top right staining example here we
put cd
20 first and it masks everything the
bottom left
we've put cd30 towards the end
and it's very difficult to see that
staining at all
and then in the bottom right what we've
done is actually to take the ab out
completely
and in this case we're using a newer
chromogen
discovery green which we
thought may help actually improve the
staining sequence
but in this case it's actually still not
optimal
the example here though where we have uh
implemented discovery green in place of
the dab
has really shown a big improvement in
the way in which we can actually
visualize these different markers
so the two uh images to the left uh
we're using
cd20 with dab and you can see we can see
some of those actual markers there but
it's very difficult to make out each of
them discreetly
on the right hand side actually what
we've done is to take away the dab
and replace it with green and by doing
that
everything becomes a lot more clear it's
much more easy to see those different
markers
because the way in which the green
chromosome works
and allows us to have better contrast
against the other
markers that we're using
where we have non-localized antigens we
have a much greater flexibility in terms
of the sequence that we're running
in this case because none of them are
co-localized
uh you can really place the chromogens
in any particular order
so here we've put cd68 as in the first
position cd8 in second
on the left hand side and then on the
right hand side we've alternated these
and you can see there's not a great deal
of difference between the staining
patterns
and this is really an important aspect
to consider
to ensure that the way in which you're
looking at these markers
and the way in which you're applying the
different chromogens to get the best
possible staining
so to summarize these um detection tips
that we've
uh mentioned and this is a recommended
chromogen sequence that we've put
together
and as you can see silver really can be
inserted anywhere within the sequence
but it's really dependent on the type of
neutralization method you may be using
if you are using h2o2 neutralization
then it's important to use this right at
the end of the sequence
also consider the masking effect of dab
particularly in co-localized markers and
how
dab could interfere with the staining of
these different
markers within the tissue red we've
found does get more pink
if it's used in later steps within the
sequence
and you definitely get a better contrast
between the red and purple
if it's applied early in the sequence
particularly before yellow and teal
as i mentioned with silver it's
important to use it at the end of the
sequence if you are using neutralization
and also teal we found does fade a
little bit if it's a
prolonged exposure to
so those are a couple of tips to
consider
so i also want to touch upon some of the
fluorescent options that we have
available for the discovery ultra as
well
uh around two uh two and a half years
ago we launched the discovery five plex
immunofluorescence procedure and with
the
iaf procedure what this offers is a more
robust
pre-optimized procedure whereby the
customer can come in
with their primary antibodies and just
excuse me apply these primary antibodies
and we've already preset the detection
order
uh and with the the uh neutralization
and denaturing steps pre-applied
so this is a lot more easy to use uh by
applying the ready-to-use products that
we have available
the customers have pretty much a plug
and play
option available to them to create a
fluorescent five plex assay
these are what the hrp fluorophores that
that we use look like uh all of these
are tyramide driven floors and we have
road domain 6g
dcc red 610 farm and cy5
one of the big benefits we found with
our products and by using the the
software that we provide
is the ability to switch easily between
brightfield
and fluorescence without the real need
to re-optimize
so for example you could could optimize
your cd3
or cd8 antibody with dab
and instead of re-optimizing for
fluorescence you can simply deselect dab
within your protocol
and then reselect one of the fluorescent
markers
and you'll get equivocal staining within
your tissue
and then within the five plex you can
build upon
these options to create up to five
different markers on the same slide so
here we have fox p3
with discovery fam we have cd68 in cy5
cd8 with discovery red 610
cd3 with dcc
we have cd20 with rhodamine 6g
and that would give you your five
different markers and this is created
with the five plex procedure
what you can also do is actually to
utilize the universal procedure within
the
discovery ultra software if you are
looking for greater flexibility
uh if the the the five plex procedure
doesn't offer you everything that you
require
so in terms of multiplexing where are we
heading uh one of the big
uh demands that we're seeing from the
clinic
and also from pharma is the
increased demand on multiplex panels or
pre-optimized fully automated
multiplex panels and specifically
disease focus
such as immuno oncology and we're also
seeing a big pull
from the chromogenic side as well as the
iaf
side
another demand that we're seeing as well
is the use of multiple
single copy mrna stains as well the
ability to detect
multiple rna or dna targets in the same
tissue
and potentially adding protein targets
with that as well
it's becoming very popular as well so an
example here within the image
is a duplex mrna stain along with
a duplex ihc as well
one of the products we're also working
on is the ability to detect
proximal events within the tissue so an
example here
is uh the ability to see where pd1 and
pdl1
is interacting not co-localizing but
interacting so when we see
a proximal event so within 14 nanometers
that is when we see staining if these
two markers are not
in proximity then we don't see any
staining
and the examples that we have here on
the right hand side is where you can see
the pd1
pdl one interactions in purple we can
see the
non-proximal events of the pd1 in yellow
and then we've also stained it with two
additional markers as well
cd8 and cd68 with ihc
so this gives a real different type of
multiplex assay with by providing a high
level of information from the particular
state
and also this could be combined with
other targets as well such as mrna
and finally in summary um with the
increased demand in multiplexing
what we're trying to do for our
customers is really increase the number
of tools available
what we're seeing is as the demand on
the number of markers increases
obviously complexity also increases
so it's really important to choose the
best method for your application
in some cases if may be the best method
in some cases brightfield may be the
best method
but it's important to look at all your
markers individually
to actually consider the type the
localization
expression levels and then alternate
detection
to determine the best fit as we saw in
some of the examples
it's very important to utilize the
ability to use the sequence
sequences within the software to create
the best possible staining combinations
and as i mentioned earlier as well there
isn't really a rule book at the moment
for multiplexing
we've got a lot of experience in this
field and by working closely with our
customers
we've tried to give the best possible
guidance for creating these types of
assays
they're not easy essays but they can
create
something which is going to provide a
high level of information for research
and hopefully within the clinic
and also allow that increased medical
value within the future
i'd like to thank you for your time and
as
xavier mentioned i'd be happy to answer
any questions that come in
via email thank you dr heliwol for that
informative presentation
i would also like to thank our sponsor
roche diagnostics for making today's
educational webcast possible
now before we go i want to let everyone
know that this webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through may of
2019
and as a final reminder any questions
submitted will be followed up with
via email buyer speaker that's all for
now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you next time goodbye